pas la peine de chercher sur une carte
ou un gps
ce village n'existe pas c'est une utopie
de simples cabanes entourées d'eau qui
défie le temps et la modernité
des familles de la région qui savoure
une vie de robinson sans eau courante ni
électricité sans réseaux pour le
téléphone portable
bienvenue à beauduc
[Musique]
s'ils étaient la plupart des cabanons
sont occupés le reste du temps seule une
poignée d'irréductibles s'accroche
contre vents et marées
[Musique]
il ya tellement de vent ça bouffe le
bois dit une vitesse là c'est frau fera
quoi être jusqu'à mots et on sort pas le
nez
chantal érudit partagent leur retraite
entre leur maison de tarascon et leur
petit cabanon de beauduc
tiens regarde
regarde la bu que j'ai un matin pour
déjeuner l'hiver il ya les oiseaux il ya
de tout
des askia de bien c'est que y'a personne
on est tranquille à le village en et une
dizaine dans le village mais bon après
l'hiver serudin il ya de l'eau partout
on peut pas trop aller nulle part
bolduc est comme une petite société
insulaire
72 cabanon qui l'hiver se retrouve vite
entouré d'eau alors ici le meilleur ami
du cabanier c'est le parpaing au monde
veut tout parce que le frigo il a pété
l'an dernier a pris l'eau et m'a fallu
changer les pièces que j'avais avec ramé
est là quand tu m'avais maintenant je
l'étais mais bon avec le réchauffement
de la terre l'ol va monter elle le fera
partir un jour on sera plus là
malheureusement je sais pas si mes
petits enfants profiteront beaucoup
mais à bonnut qu on n'est pas du genre à
se résigner tout de suite
plutôt à se retrousser les manches pour
conserver son idéal de vie et sa petite
maison
c'est vrai le village est en sursis la
montée des eaux est une menace prise au
sérieux au large d'anciennes du gant
déjà cédé
[Musique]
la mer est désormais aux portes du
village et les irréductibles de beauduc
mène un combat incessant et peut-être
insensée contre ces assauts répétés
ce matin rudy et ses compagnons doivent
de toute urgence colmater une brèche
dans une des digues qui protègent le
village
on a émis du plastique à copines on
n'avait pas bien avec lui je passe
cloclo samedi partira pas dans sa
version
à coups de clous rouillés et de sable il
bricole un rempart de fortune dérisoire
barrage face à la méditerranée
il ya un mètre d'eau là derrière si on
regarde papa tout le temps là de
nombreux villages comme ça se protège
tous
yan proulx
avec la sicaudais nord
ouais mais le servir à sortir par là
la leader dans des villes
les cabanes ils se sont cotisés pour
acheter cet engin de chantier
indispensable à leur survie aux manettes
c'est georges l'un des rares à vivre à
beauduc à l'année
s'en sort c'est le prix à payer
trempés par le sable et l'eau de mer la
machine s'est enrayée
georges doit battre en retraite
heureusement la digue a pu être colmatée
attend
le village est provisoirement sauvé sa
peau ses peintures dont
likouala bas
à beauduc mieux vaut être prévoyant et
savoir réparer toutes les pannes
il faut en effet plus d'une heure de
voiture pour rejoindre le magasin le
plus proche du coup on découvre que
l'atelier de georges n'a rien à envier
aux plus grosses enseignes de bricolage
on sent qu on se trompe pas de pouvoir y
revenir
je crois au but tuer
sa tranquillité
mais une tranquillité toute relative car
forcément avec sa caisse à outils george
est sans cesse sollicité
sur un message
dans son autour du cas banon
dans la vie georges et pêcheurs
professionnels
il vit à beauduc depuis 40 ans et à tout
aménagé pour être 100% autonome
de trois batteries il ya un régulateur
puis après un convertisseur
dicro panneaux solaires chaque année par
soleil soutient les éoliennes s'il ya du
vin
il ya passé ben ya un groupe électrogène
qui est qui qui avait que des chargeurs
qui change
un jour il y aura l'électricité cie
courant
pas du tout nous n'avons pas
fait ça est récitée l'eau en récupérant
l'eau de pluie on a assez on n'en veut
pas être cité le jour qu il yal et
réciter le coran dit si ça changeait
complète havas n'a plus rien à voir
comment je parle bien sûr quand on voit
ce qu'est la non là tu l'as toujours eu
en moi c'est moi qui les fais
là la pudeur
la plus de vingt-cinq 25 à 30 ans
et aucune règle chacun fait la cabane
qu'il avait envie de faire comme moi la
kaaba c'est la base quand tu passes à
faire une cabale anti chrétiennes
quelques gamins et il faisait des
cabanes l'institut réalise ton rêve tu
fais ta cabane et nous sommes plus qu'à
bâle mais c'est notre maison
oui
tous les matins un jour chantal fait le
tour des cabanes occupé pour prendre des
nouvelles de ses voisins
george n'y échappe pas au rituel aille
mal rasé ouais un petit peu mais tu
'piquer'
tupi que tu piques à
six voies sa lunette georges à la jeu
pour dire non
wendy mauvaise au mois de comme tu
travailles il me faut des lunettes
saül genre je crois que le village
serait plus là
notre pilier george
nab de luire et puis c'est beaucoup de
choses que les jeunes ne savent pas et
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui l'écoutent
voilà il ya des personnes qui dort et le
créneau
one oranje restent
chez les gros nounours chantier parce
qu'il est toujours mal rasé
on te met saute derrière sur la tête
pour se faire caresser
[Musique]
l'histoire de beauduc commence dans les
années 50
quelques cabane abandonnée de pêcheurs
que des familles d'ouvriers des salins
mais aussi des retraités améliore pour
venir passer des vacances ou des week
end
puis est arrivé le camping sauvage sur
la plage le phénomène prend de l'ampleur
à partir des années 80 des milliers de
caravanes et de cabanes envahissent
régulièrement le domaine public maritime
depuis les autorités ont mis le holà
finie la zone libre de beauduc
aujourd'hui seuls quelques privilégiés
ont encore le droit d'occuper les
cabanes du quartier historique
ce couple qui emprunte de nuit la piste
qui mène à beauduc fait partie de ces
privilégiés
allez
monuc nous voilà john et julie vivent et
travaillent en belgique depuis sept ans
il n'hésite pas à faire chaque été plus
d'un millier de kilomètres pour
rejoindre l'eldorado où il avait
l'habitude de camper mais cette fois
c'est différent il y a trois mois le
couple a réalisé son rêve devenir
propriétaire d'un cabanon à beauduc le
bonheur quelque part c'est une fois
qu'on est sur la piste il ya plus de
réseau gsm plus rien
le client plus de
deux patrons peu plus de gens pour nous
embêter
[Musique]
avec leur fils james il profite d'un
week-end prolongé pour investir leur
nouvelle tanière
[Musique]
chantal allumer le feu c'est qui qui est
venu nous allumer le poêle et surtout
c'est sympa d'avoir deux amis à beauduc
c'est un rêve
et puis là maintenant pouvoir venir
l'hiver en automne
tout le temps c'est chez nous c'est à
nous enfin
quelle chance quelle chanson née
[Musique]
d'habitude les cabanes se transmettent
entre proches dans les familles il est
très rare qu'elle se vende à des
étrangers
mais après des années de camping sauvage
d'apéritif de fête d'entr'aide tout un
parcours initiatique john et julie ont
finalement su se faire accepter des
cabaniers historique et c'est cette
amitié qui leur a permis naturellement
de devenir aujourd'hui propriétaires
sont bien
ceux qui essaient de leur cabanon ils
ont envie de le céder vraiment à
quelqu'un qui a un esprit baugé qui a un
qui a envie d'y vivre qui veut
entretenir les cabanons les décors et en
faire un petit bijou a eu
leur petit nid et donc voilà c'est ça
qui a fait que ça on a eu cette
opportunité
ça ne se vend pas devant le ter sa sauce
aide ça se transmet donc j'aime bien
cette cette notion de justement de
transmission d'un patrimoine
finalement plus culturelle que purement
immobilier on arrête de dire les belges
il faut qu'on dise julie
dans le village il disait alors je
voulais belge segebel annoncé julie et
john ya des personnes d'ici qui ont un
cabanon qui ne viennent jamais mieux qui
avait pas de cabanons idole au coeur à
baudu déjà donc c'était automatique au
ban des cavaliers
s'étaient d'office et des cavaliers il
était cavalier avoir d'avoir un cabanon
john et julie sont propriétaires du bâti
mais pas du terrain qui appartient la
société des salins du midi et c'est le
cas pour toutes les constructions de
bonus
[Musique]
mais qu'importe car posséder un
pied-à-terre dans ce bout du monde c'est
déjà un privilège
et donc on va accéder comment par la
plage un privilège qui s'apprivoise et
s'apprend avec ses codes et ses astuces
et tu pense qu'on va trouver du bois
flotté
[Musique]
ici récupérer et recycler tout ce qui
peut l'être c'est un art et une évidence
pas question de courir les magasins
mais pas question non plus de se couper
des traditions l'idée c'est de trouver
tous des bois pour faire un sapin parce
que le prochain séjour on a en fait un
réveillon tout le monde est là donc il
faut notre sapin
[Musique]
par définition un petit trou là ouais
c'est pas une petite ficelle et puis tu
panda tant d'arbres de noël ah oui pour
fermer des boules de noël
ce soir c'est la course pour james et sa
maman
maintenant il faut faire beaucoup plus
que ça oui mais en fait à chaque fois
parce que pour les doses julie a invité
une partie du village pour son
anniversaire si tu dois bien tous collés
ensemble qui peut tout écraser les
outils de grands mères sont sortis donc
quand même il ya moyen sans croûte à la
force du poignet tout est mis en oeuvre
pour conquérir le coeur des cabaniers
historique
c'est tout le monde parce que si tu
commence à arriver ici et tu t'en sors
avec personne tu peux pas rester faux
frais mais
fêtes
apéritif fut la passion de la passion
mais déjà ils sont 28 ans
[Musique]
c'est là et on avait très diverses au
même jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après une courte nuit le plus ancien des
cabaniers est déjà sur le pont de son
bateau
georges peut vivre toute l'année à
beauduc car il exerce le métier de
pêcheur sur place une passion qui l'a
transmise à son neveu qui l'accompagnent
à chaque sortie
j'ai
fréquenté les pêcheurs qui a réussi six
enfants
comme tous les pêcheurs le moral de
georges remonte au rythme des filets
[Musique]
après des petits requins sans valeur de
belles daurade bien dodues font bientôt
leur apparition
[Musique]
une belle pêche que le neveu de georges
ira vendre à la criée de port saint
louis du rhône
à terre le bois flotté ramassé la veille
entame une seconde vie dans la nouvelle
maison de john et julie
petit à petit toute la famille
s'approprie son petit coin de paradis
[Musique]
et sans ordinateur sans travail sans ce
qu'il l'opposé de ma vie ou de notre vie
en belgique on court tout le temps pour
tout et c'est comme ça que j'ai décrit
monuc france est un une parenthèse c'est
la liberté belgique
[Musique]
mamad
à